a popular tourist destination on Lake
Tahoe is in the middle of a growing
battle over vacation rental homes the
city of South Lake Tahoe recently
increased fines for noise and parking
violations to one thousand dollars it is
part of an effort to address the
dramatic increase in vacation homes
available on internet rental sites
Carter Evans reports from the mountain
town along the california/nevada border
good morning when you visit a resort
community like this you're looking
forward to spending time in the great
outdoors and you're probably not
expecting pamphlets from the city
explaining rules visitors have to follow
to avoid getting a thousand dollar fine
on their vacation surrounded by the
Sierra Nevada Lake Tahoe is an Alpine
paradise that attracts nearly 3 million
visitors each year but in the small
community of South Lake Tahoe longtime
resident Peggy Borland says tourists are
taking over what has changed the game up
here well the internet and these these
vacation platforms there are 1,800
rental properties in this small city
this one right here is a vacation rental
and the two large ones there are both
vacation rentals Borland says it's
changing the community and she'd like to
ban rentals altogether in residential
areas well the truth comes here they
anticipate they can do whatever they
want to do and they want to be in a hot
tub late at night or they want to you
know have friends over and all these
things it's just not compatible with our
residential neighborhoods the city
changed its ordinance after neighbors
raised concerns it now finds both the
vacation home owner and the renter 1,000
dollars each for things like parking on
the street at anytime having too many
houseguests or getting into the hot tub
after 10:00 p.m. this new ordinance
doesn't make any sense whatsoever it is
totally punitive and totally unfair
Silicon Valley entrepreneur Jonathan
Miller says his Tahoe rental home is
part of his retirement plan imagine if
you come to Tahoe here
suddenly somebody parks the for a minute
on the street they get a thousand dollar
fine how are they gonna feel about that
ok they're gonna hate Tahoe they're
gonna hate California they're never
coming back here again here is our
beautiful hot tub
he's received two fines and under the
city's updated rules if he gets one more
ticket he'll be banned from renting his
home for life I don't want to feel like
I'm unwelcome I mean that doesn't make
any sense at all I'm contributing to the
city's economy one my being punished for
that why that large a number they need
to have strong fines so that we can
ensure the peace and tranquility of our
neighbors Mayor Wendy David says she's
trying to strike a balance within this
tourism community the city relies on
vacation rentals for three million
dollars in taxes it's a struggle facing
an increasing number of cities there's
about 2,700 cities across North America
now that has more than 100 short-term
rentals and so this is not just a big
city or coastal or like kinda like ski
resort issue this is a national issue or
like Benzer is the CEO of host
compliance a company that helps local
governments track and tax vacation
rentals the company says the number of
listings has increased about 800 percent
in the last eight years to 2.3 million
cities like New Orleans Nashville and
Palm Springs are engaged in similar
fights over whether rentals should be
allowed so you don't think these fines
are the solution no it's it's a big
bandaid on a problem that has to be
solved in a different way some community
members now want to take this directly
to the voters and if they get enough
signatures on their petition the issue
of whether or not to ban vacation
rentals entirely here will be on the
ballot in November for CBS this morning
Carter Evans South Lake Tahoe I'm
feeling a little
womp-womp debbie downer I mean if I
didn't know better I would think they
don't want vacation people there a time
limit on the hot tub
everybody knows all the good stuff
happens everybody knows that we're all
adults in the room I don't know I don't
think that at all
a thousand dollars for parking no so if
you're on the internet trying to
vacation pick your vacation home for the
summer figure that out before you go and
it becomes a thousand dollars more than
you guessed
John Dickerson stop the schoolboy Act
you know a hot good hot dog